the illusions that we talked about have
one main thing in common most of them
are over estimations of our cognitive
abilities or another way putting that is
an underappreciated hiren limits on our
cognitive abilities we don't appreciate
the limits on how much we can pay
attention to it once and therefore we
think we can multitask better than we
can we don't appreciate the limits what
we actually store in memory and
therefore we think our memories are more
accurate than they are how do we solve
this problem well one would be raising
those limits or taking them away
entirely somehow enabling our brains to
pay attention to more things at once or
our memories to store things more
accurately and retrieve them more
accurately and so on that might be
technologically possible in some sense
and in fact many technologies that we've
invented over recorded history are
designed to increase our cognitive
limitations why do we write things down
because oral tradition is not as good a
way of conveying information as written
history we have lots of devices that
enable us to do things like that better
so technological solutions may help us
to increase some of those limits but
there's a fundamental problem that sort
of gets in the way of that which is that
we have these illusions or sort of false
intuitions about those limits in the
first place so really what people can do
and what they ought to do is think a
little bit more about how their
intuitions about the mind might be wrong
sort of take to heart some of the
examples that we talk about and not be
so certain of themselves and not be so
angry at other people who might be
suffering from these illusions that
affect all of us rather than being
malicious or having some other bad
motives
the American legal system is one which
makes a lot of sort of assumptions and
common sense and use a lot of common
sense beliefs about how the mind works
in its own procedures for example
eyewitness testimony is thought to be an
extremely high valued form of testimony
if someone says I saw that guy do it
that's about the strongest testimony you
can get in fact other kinds of evidence
is sort of sometimes derisively labeled
circumstantial as though that somehow
worse than eyewitness testimony but what
research over decades by many
psychologists have shown is that
eyewitness testimony is in many ways
less than it's cracked up to me because
I witnesses are just as fallible as the
rest of us in terms of how their
memories work and they're just as
unlikely to notice things they're just
as likely to distort them in their
memory over time there have been many
cases where eyewitness testimony
convicted someone they went as far as
death row and were exonerated by DNA
evidence and it was found that someone
else did it cases where the witness was
incredibly confident on the stand and
this is a place where sort of memory and
confidence illusions interplay if
someone thinks their memory is more
accurate than they are and they're
really poised and confident and
convincing on the witness stand then
you're in trouble if you're the
defendant who didn't do it and the
synergy between those illusions can
really be powerful in the case of the
legal system the legal system in my
opinion needs to sort of come to grips
more with the way the mind actually
works and the kinds of beliefs that we
have about the mind which aren't
actually true maybe rely a little less
somehow uncommon sense and a little more
on scientific evidence about how the
mind works